[Music]
yeah
okay kitten
yes in principle you could do that but
you aren't going to design a spacesuit
that could be that easily disabled and
destroyed hi gq this is kathy lewis i'm
curator of spacesuits at the smithsonian
air and space museum and this is the
breakdown
[Music]
first up star trek
[Music]
star trek was made during the height of
the apollo program
so they weren't going to use spacesuits
that looked like apollo spacesuits they
had to reinforce the idea that they were
centuries into the future so what they
have are featured of new materials
a transparent yet completely impermeable
material that would be
fantastic to use and make from but it's
something that doesn't exist in our
world today these helmets are differ
from from what we expect as helmets
they're not sort of round shaped to the
head they're sort of a square shaped
they have a very wide field of vision
that not only gives the hypothetical
astronaut the ability to view the world
but it also gives the audience the
ability to view
the astronaut's face
so you can see who the cast is who is
speaking this is an actual apollo bubble
helmet when i complain about helmets
being too large this is what i mean this
is not so much bigger than your head and
one of the tests of pilots and
astronauts is seeing if they can put the
helmet on and not feel claustrophobic
astronauts can look up look down and see
their toes look to the left and right of
themselves but they've not got a whole
lot of space between
the nose and the edge of the helmet
what's fascinating is whatever material
they're using
as the face mask it's it doesn't seem to
be
that type of hard polycarbonate material
that we use in spacesuits today it seems
to be some sort of flexible
but permeable um and hardened material
that is unlike something that we've ever
seen before all of the tubing is on the
outside of the suit so that must mean
that the tubing that supplies oxygen
removes the carbon dioxide is very very
hard and puncture resistant because you
don't want your oxygen supply exposed
and vulnerable to any sort of accident
so these are stretchable fabrics they
don't seem to be constricting they don't
seem to be weighty these aren't heavy
spacesuits these are
very lightweights the actors are able to
squat down bend over and move around
pretty freely pretty much as freely as
they would in their regular costume
gravity
sorry i'm done it's done kowalski
initiate emergency disconnect from the
hubble all right sharif let's do this
houston update well we have a full-on
chain reaction it's been confirmed that
it's the unintentional side effect of
the russians striking one of their own
satellites the suits that sandra bullock
and george clooney are wearing are
replicas of the current spacesuit
assembly of extra vehicular mobility
unit nobody says that it's the ssa emu
and these are very close other than
having the helmet expand they're very
close to what the astronauts use from
the space station today to perform space
walks they're just tethered
very tightly they work around spacecraft
and the international space station by
climbing across handholds and footholds
first of all is the size of the helmet
they make the helmet enlarged so you can
see who it is
who's acting
that's a standard complaint that i have
with with
most all spacesuit movies the other
factor is the use of the man maneuvering
unit that george clooney use
this was a technology that nasa tried
during the 1980s and they stopped using
it with the challenger explosion because
it was too risky it has what engineers
refer to as a single point of failure
system george clooney is bouncing into
very expensive very heavy uh equipment
every time he goes around um that man
maneuvering unit was made to have very
self produce very subtle movement
in space um you don't want to be
bouncing into in into spacecraft into
the hubble space telescope
the laws of physics are still maintained
up in space even in the movies that
bubble helmet
is very shatterproof it was based on
designs of cockpit bubbles from world
war ii and it is molded by a liquid
laminar flow molding technique makes it
very resilient it's very crack proof
it's multi-layered and it snugly fits
over the astronaut's head it's very
important to have something that is
clear um doesn't
impact the astronaut's field of vision
but also is very sturdy and holds that
air inside
the spacesuit for the astronaut to be
able to breathe freely and look around
and see what he or she is doing there
are certain
shortcuts that the director takes just
to make to the point
there are no liquid cooling garments the
director
uses
launch and entry suits which are really
only made to work inside a spacecraft
with eva suits and that's kind of a
problem because we'd like to make that
distinction for our audience to
understand that there's a big difference
between the suits you see astronauts
marching out to a spacecraft prior to
launching and the ones that they use
actually to perform space walks
alien
[Music]
when sigourney weaver climbs into the
spacesuit she does it with an amazing
amount of ease obviously she has to do
that for the plot of the movie but she's
not pre-breathing oxygen one assumes
that she would need to in order to
prepare for the all oxygen environment
of the spacesuit
she snaps it on very quickly there are
no parts um it looks a little odd just
because it looks as though the spacesuit
might be too big for her she's barely
looking over the into the visor
which is surprising given sigourney
weaver's height you wouldn't think that
she would have a spacesuit that would be
much larger than she and once again the
helmet is really really large i assume
just so we can see sigourney weaver's
face the other question i have is what
is the purpose of the those openings in
the helmet
towards the back of her head we don't
see her sealing the spacesuit at all we
just see her climbing in and velcroing
it up we don't see
a pressure layer of the suit that the
layer that usually a rubber or a
synthetic layer that keeps the oxygen
inside that performs the purpose of
being a bladder inside the suit what you
do see is a
thermal micro medial garment layer that
outer layer that we we associate with
spacesuits and that's to protect against
particles traveling very fast in space
it's also to protect against radiation
from whatever source you know we're out
here someplace in the galaxy i don't
know where but there still are going to
be sources of radiation some sort of
solar radiation
as opposed to existing radiation in the
suit so
that suit itself looks very bulky but
it's similar in the way that apollo
suits look very bulky not necessarily
very heavy weight
but
but thick
and protective i remember seeing this
movie as a young girl in high school and
it was really a landmark case of having
a woman being the hero of a movie i
cheered her
prometheus
hey wallace
take a look at this
the really particular egregious thing i
see about this helmet is that it
shatters and it shatters almost like
glass one thing that you that engineers
and technicians design helmets for
are purposely to be shatter proof seeing
that shattering would require an immense
amount of force far more than any
creature could exert in order to shatter
somebody else's helmet they test helmets
for this this sort of collision and
impact well the helmet shattering
implies that
the astronaut loses
his or her oxygen supply basically if
you lose your oxygen supply in a vacuum
or
in a toxic environment
you have about 15 seconds of
consciousness left after that unless
somebody gets to you and rescues you and
gets you
back to a breathable atmosphere you have
about two or three minutes before you
die once you're dead you will go through
the normal things that will happen
in a
environment your your gases will start
to bubble out of your system
you'll form
icicles in your tear ducts and in your
mouth
but pretty much you'll be
desiccated over time and you'll be
desiccated faster than you will explode
or or or expand as much as we we see in
the movies so it would be
near instant death
and after that not really dramatic
the martian
i know for a fact that ridley scott
worked really closely with nasa on this
movie there are certain protective
aspects of the space suit that are on
the exterior which looks strange but um
why not it's it's interesting there are
the caps over the knees and the
shoulders and the elbows sort of like
skate guards but these are necessary
components that are embedded in
spacesuits even today
just to make sure those exposed joints
that have to be mobile for human being
to do meaningful work but also have to
be protected because they are very
vulnerable and that mobility allows the
suit itself to stretch and bend but it
has to be protected because that
stretching and bending also allows a
greater vulnerability to penetration to
sharp objects to falls the backpack the
life support backpack is very small to
my eyes it's certainly smaller than what
astronauts used on the moon and what
astronauts use onboard the international
space station but that too is reasonable
when you think about it that they made
some of the systems more compact the
oxygen may be compressed the instruments
that
take out the carbon dioxide in the air
well there nasa is working on trying to
perfect that system to make it smaller
more compact and rechargeable the only
thing that i i find curious and
interesting about this one
is the fact that the visor there is a
visor which is basically a tinted um
sunglass but it's mounted on the inside
of the the helmet not on the outside of
the helmet as it is today and has been
so i'm wondering how he would be able to
lower that visor if he was facing in the
sun because you really need that i don't
know if he'd reach in or that he had
some sort of external button that he
would
press to raise or lower it he seems to
be wearing some sort of a pressure suit
a compression suit much like compression
shorts that you wear on a bike or
performing weight lifting and that
compression suit is keeping the pressure
up on his body and then the rest of the
suit is dedicated to protecting from
outside threads so he's got the the
atmosphere replacement compression
built into the suit so we don't see it
so it doesn't look as bulky but that's
something that that engineers are
working on nasa's thinking about people
working on it at mit
and at university of north dakota among
other places with the most recent mars
mission
they have sent materials that they're
planning to use for spacesuits up to
mars just to see how they how they age
and sometime in the future we'll get
those materials back and be able to
examine them spacesuit engineers tend to
be very cautious they don't want to use
the most high-tech materials until they
know how they perform over the long term
they're very concerned about protecting
human lives and knowing every possible
alternative that could arise when using
the spacesuit
moonraker
[Music]
pause here there are a lot of things
going on in this movie many things i
have questions about other things that
are very
eerily familiar the spacesuits
themselves seem to be taken from
suits that were either prototypes or
designs from the mid-1960s which isn't
surprising but it's very interesting of
course once again they have these these
fictional man maneuvering units that
have very accurate and steady ability to
maneuver the astronauts
what really gets me is that these guys
are firing these the these met weapons
that have no recoil whatsoever they're
firing them and they aren't being pushed
back
defies all sorts of physics the suits
shown in here
date back
to the 1960s the orangish suits resemble
the flight suits that pilots high
performance
test pilots were wearing during the
1960s the silver suits in fact look very
much like prototypes that were proposed
at the beginning of the apollo program
those sort of large flat fishbowl type
helmets were were used as prototypes you
see the astronauts in the cockpit of the
spacecraft and they have this silver
metallicized
spacesuit which is very much resembles
the mercury space suits that we remember
the mercury seven wearing for their
first american space flights but they're
also remem resemble suits that
experimental pilots were wearing on the
x-15 as well it's the suit that neil
armstrong wore when he got his astronaut
wings before he joined nasa so it's very
interesting that they've adopted
all sorts of existing technologies and
then added on
these these hypothetical maneuvering
units and these recoil-less
laser guns
pew pew that's that's all i can say
destination moon
i check radios
tech instruments check air
now let's go
i'm going to get another line
[Music]
this is a space history classic
this is everyone who is involved in the
history of space exploration has seen
this movie many many times the
preparation for the suit yes it's not as
elaborate as what we know today but this
is the 1950s they figured out a lot here
they prepped for the suit they um use
their oxygen hoses and we're breathing
inside the suits before they
depressurize their spacecraft
there's little subtle things that i've
noticed and looking at it the spacesuit
starts to expand a little bit as they do
pressurize the spacecraft that's very
important of course your spacesuit is
going to expand in a vacuum because it's
pressing out with the oxygen inside and
there's nothing pressing back in they
check their communications
before they depressurize they're doing
all of that prep and then when they open
the capsule door they look out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that is the most common
pause that astronauts speak of when they
make their first space walk when they go
out there they do have that sensation
that they're going to fall
and it
is very common you get over it very
quickly because you've trained for it
but if you have a lay person come out
yeah you're going to feel like you're
falling because you are falling you're
orbiting the earth at a very high rate
of speed and that orbit means that
you're falling at a high rate of speed
you're just falling at a rate of speed
that takes you over the the horizon as
fast as you're falling so you're not
going to fall back to earth but you do
have that falling sensation and looking
out there are folds in the knees and the
elbows to allow mobility in a
pressurized suit that pressurized suit
goes from being sort of slack and limp
um under pressure inside the spacecraft
to being a little harder to push against
when you're pushing against that oxygen
filled suit and that makes internal
movement
much more difficult
to push around that oxygen and the
compression um that is keeping that
oxygen in holding up against the body
yes they didn't make it all the way to
the bubble helmet design but that wasn't
designed until the mid-1960s these suits
seem to be based on largely what we know
about
diving suits
about flight suits for astronauts
and what we were pretty
certain we knew about the environment of
space at this point no one had gone into
space not even like the dog so we really
didn't know what was going to happen
what materials we need we knew we needed
insulating materials we needed a way to
keep the oxygen inside a way to
continuously communicate with ground
control and each other
they need to speak to each other a way
to see we were looking at new materials
but
people at that time didn't have an idea
what those new materials would be of
course in space
things don't have a weight but they
continue to have a mess so you don't
want to have
something incredibly massive that would
be
very prohibitive to motion to move
around these suits have
you know they look like a polyester
synthetic material to me um which makes
sense you want something lightweight but
you also want something standardized
something that you wouldn't get with a
natural fiber a wool or a cotton
stargate atlantis
what are you waiting for
i have to pull the right one or the
antenna explodes
[Music]
hurry up
but get it right
this is a
very different approach to spacesuits
than than other films that i've seen
this goes back to that old
armor
style conception of a spacesuit and they
seem to be have wearing some sort of
suit of armor with a helmet that
actually does
fit their heads so you don't have that
excess volume of air floating around
that you don't need and carrying around
so it's very different in that terms we
can only guess on what sort of fantastic
futuristic material this armor is made
from it's obviously jointed it allows
the person wearing it to bend down and
move around fairly freely we don't know
the environment that they're in entirely
so we don't know whether it's a vacuum
or not the exterior of the spacesuit is
very intriguing very different from from
what we've seen before what's really
interesting is this use of the heads-up
display the projection
inside the helmet
that is something that helmet makers
be it for astronauts or pilots have been
aspiring to
for
for decades in real life and their
problems with that um this seems to
overcome it by having a solid helmet and
the projection on the inside so the
astronaut doesn't have a very deep field
of vision exterior to his spacesuit but
he has all the information he needs is
coming up on the inside of that helmet
which is really neat really the problem
with using heads-up display and helmets
the way we use them today
is that if you're out
on another world if you're on an
orbiting space station you're going to
get solar glare and you're not going to
be able to see that heads-up display
when the sun passes in front of you or
if you turn your head and you know
facing the sun or wherever you're
looking so it's very awkward but
this
suit designer a costume designer has
come up with an ingenious way to make
make heads up display work um it's like
having a console or having a console on
your face um much like you know with
what we do now for virtual reality and
that works so that that's very
intriguing it's it's a different
approach and if
astronauts are willing to give up being
able to see their feet as they walk
that'll work fine you just have to
change the culture
armageddon
[Music]
me a favor wait
just tell grace that i'm
i'll always be with her okay
can you do that
yeah
okay kitten
mr truman oh make sure and get that
it's my turn now
armageddon is supposed to be
set in the not-too-distant future and
the spacesuits used in it are
pretty much in the not too distant
future they very closely resemble the
basic principles of what we
build on for spacesuits today they seem
to have some sort of
physical mechanical compression device
and these tubings that run along that
the lateral lines of the muscles of the
body the helmets are appropriately sized
i'm very glad to say the placement of
the the lights on the helmet are very
good they're on the exterior of the
helmet it would allow the astronaut to
see
in front of them and examine things
closely they don't have a thermal micro
meteor garment shrouding the helmet but
under these circumstances
it's really not necessary and
theatrically it's not as necessary what
catches me
are
the
dramatic transitions in the movie
that
really couldn't be done with spacesuits
or you hope they wouldn't be able to do
them with spacesuits first of all is
bruce willis pulling the oxygen supply
from ben affleck yes in principle you
could do that but you aren't going to
design a spacesuit that could be that
easily disabled and destroyed bruce
willis tearing his
patch off of his spacesuit with his
gloved hand
the first lesson that astronauts today
learn when they're practicing for space
walks
they put on their spacesuits they go
down into the neutral buoyancy tank in
houston and
they're confronted with
coins usually dimes on the bottom of
this huge um swimming pool that they
they
enact space walks in with the help of
weights and scuba divers and their
assignment is to figure out a way to
pick up those coins on the bottom of the
pool it is really hard to
exhibit any sort of manual dexterity in
a pressurized glove picking up coins you
can probably finesse by grabbing and
dragging them along and getting that
that flip but getting something as
tactile as ripping
a patch which is very well sewn with
very strong
synthetic thread onto a spacesuit is not
going to happen but if you hadn't done
that you wouldn't have had the dramatic
conclusion of the movie and you know
this return of the patch back to the the
earthbound flight director who had
always wanted to go into space so that
that's very important for them the movie
to flow but not very practical to do
inside a spacesuit the one thing that
they do get right is that affleck falls
back into the chamber and the door is
closed and repressurized within that 15
seconds so he doesn't lose consciousness
he is returned restored to a safe
environment very quickly so that makes
it easy
2001 a space odyssey
[Applause]
[Music]
yet another classic in in space movies
the fact is that kubrick was good um he
relied on the state-of-the-art
techniques
in special effects well informed by what
was then the current state of the art of
spacesuit design in fact this spacesuit
is very similar to a prototype that had
been proposed to nasa during the early
1960s for the apollo program it has
this helmet that has a you know sort of
a conical shaped helmet but it has a
very wide range of vision so the
astronaut can turn his head left or
right and see everything around him or
pretty much everything around him the
spacesuit itself is
really interesting because it
employs that
tomato worm design those are the sort of
corrugated forms along the legs and the
arms and that is a method in which
oxygen would be able to be displaced
locally so when the astronaut bent his
or her arm compressed the air on one
side and the air would flow to the
outside of the compressed joint instead
of
forcing the the other arm to go out or
the leg to go out straight so it's a
localized
displacement of oxygen there is a very
small backpack or front pack for the
astronauts to control their oxygen
supply
the hands are in what looks to be sort
of a rubber dip glove not a great deal
of tactile sensation but at least enough
for
him to work in he decided to use
something
that didn't look like a nasa suit at the
time but he also stayed very close to
what was reality or what was practical
or what what
spacesuit engineers were thinking about
at the time he was aware that they were
worried about field of vision he knew
that mobility
in a pressurized suit in a vacuum
was very difficult and very awkward he
was very concerned with with getting it
right and getting it accurate obviously
he's working with arthur c clarke who
understood the very importance that you
know we couldn't make this as wild and
fantastic as possible we had to draw
back to
our real expectations of what the future
that the near future would look like
this is my my
all-time favorite scene in a space
science fiction movie he's used the
explosive propulsion of depressurizing
his shuttle vehicle to get him into the
airlock
now yes it's not very probable that he
would go straight in and the explosive
compression would drive him just to the
precise point in the airlock so he could
tap on that door and have the door
closed and the lock repressurized within
that that very special 15 seconds but
it's a wonderful scene and it teaches
you a lot about physics and it reminds
you that we're dealing with a real world
out there
outland
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
the flashlights the light bulbs they're
inside the helmets
um you don't want to do that i don't
know if any of you remember the first
time you had a fish tank or a fish ball
and you shined a light on the outside
and you couldn't see to the other side
that's the same thing that happens if
you have the lights inside a spacesuit
inside a space helmet you're not going
to be able to see it's it's blinding you
have that reflection in order to design
these suits they would have to
know what the environment is so they
have to be pretty confident that the the
pressure is going to be constant but
that the gravity is going to be constant
jupiter's moons are irregular that means
that the gravity may be irregular you
may have
different levels of gravity depending on
where it is in orbit or what other moons
it's coming in encountering at the time
because moons have their own
gravitational attraction so this is a
pretty complicated calculus to work on
when you're talking about anticipating
what a spacesuit is going to do and
anticipating what it's going to need to
do
how it's going to function in an alien
environment and how it is going to
compensate for the variations of of
gravity
atmosphere
and structure and also construction
building spacesuits for construction is
probably the hardest thing to do because
you're putting people in suits to
protect them at probably the most
perilous state in in
orchestrating large movements of objects
and materials
moon
[Music]
i'm a really
great fan of dark dystopian movies and
this movie hits it for me this has
spacesuits that closely resemble apollo
spacesuits with the expectation that
this too is not the too distant future
there are obviously modifications
updates on the suit but it still has the
same basic bubble helmet this shroud on
top that projects that also mounts
lights potentially cameras obviously the
actor is not wearing a full spacesuit
it's a little bit too loose it's not
pressing up against pressing out against
the vacuum of space but it's pretty on
target from what a moon worker clone
would probably be issued to wear
sunshine
these helmets look like something that
were proposed back in the 1950s these
giant almost dragon looked like helmets
that were over
really overbearing and you wonder what
their function is for the suit itself
it looks a little large very bulky and
it has it's sort of
incorporated both its protection and its
mobility on the outside you see the
rings around the elbows and the knees
and the hips but you also see that sort
of heavy material that is protecting the
wearer inside the suit so you wonder if
it's all in one or if this is closer to
a spacecraft itself well one interesting
thing about being in close proximity of
the sun is that it isn't the same as
being in close proximity to a stove with
a stove you have heat can radiate
through the air
with the sun because there is a vacuum
you can get very close to the sun
without getting very hot and we've
learned recently with solar probes and
exploration that you can get very close
in and if you pull back quickly enough
the the satellite the probe can survive
so you can go back and forth just taking
advantage of that vacuum between you and
the sun so you don't need that heavy
protection but you need to make your
calculations very quickly and make sure
you avoid solar flares this may be
so bulky just to compensate not only for
the sun but for the nuclear radiation of
reigniting the sun so this may have a
dual purpose of protection and that
might explain why why it is so bulky
gold is is
the universal or not universal but
global
reflective material if you go to the air
and space museum today you will see the
the skylab has a gold finish on it and
that too is a layer of monomolecular
gold which reflects back the sun
very uniformly
so it dissipates heat radiation coming
from the sun
so we know that gold works that it you
know it's not only just pretty and
glittery but it has a very very sound
function for dissipating radiation and
light thank you for watching these clips
with me i hope you learned something i
hope you enjoyed it and until next time
[Music]